[Música]
olha aí ó ISS é o qu carro de som porque
carro de som é o seguinte ele só aparece
quando você tá fazendo alguma coisa eu
tava a tarde todinha sem fazer nada eu
disse vou gravar começou o diabo do
carro de som aqui fora parece que o cara
do carro de som ele fica olhando PR você
ele fica esperando você fazer alguma
coisa O cara tá de boa aqui tá tranquilo
levanta vou fazer alguma
coisa carro do alho está passando na sua
rua a você sai de casa PR V Celta com á
e nessa época a gente tá pior por porque
começou as políticas e eu vivi minha
vida inteira cidade de interior pô
quando eu não tava em B Jesus eu tava em
Santa Luz que são duas cidades
pequenininhas uma perto da outra e aí
começa que [__] a eleição é em outubro
em maio eles estão com os carros de
sonho pro lado de cá não sei que não sei
interior tem muito isso muita carriata e
é os carros um atrás do outro
pi eu f no 42 e a msca pro lado de cá
vai pulando vai e pula pula pula pula
lado de cá